So, this is the heart of a data center. It's a server room. It's one of the ten giant server rooms...
...at this particular center with as many as 30,000 servers,...
...and each of them all possess a vast amount of computing power, and an awful lot of storage.
And all part really of this big ramping output of cloud computers.
And here's Mike Menaz from Microsoft, you run the data center operations.
Mike, just give us a sense of the scale, how much can be stored in a place like this?
Well, I did a little calculations and if we apply it to something that everyone likes to do,...
...which is storing pictures up on the Internet,...
...a facility of this size can house somewhere in the neighborhood of 6.75 trillion photos...
...for the users of our cloud applications.
Now, people will be worried about a couple of things. They'll be worried about security...
...in terms of people getting hold of their data. They'll be worried about what happens if a place like this shuts down.
Well, from a security perspective and from a redundancy perspective, a facility like this is pretty hardened.
As you probably saw as you came in, security is pretty tight on the outside.
Logically, in terms of getting access to your data,...
...we have pretty significant security measures deployed to protect the users.
If the facility were to go down, if there was a catastrophic event, for example,...
...we have the ability in our application software, in our cloud infrastructure,...
...to fill all of this over to other facilities.
So, you'll never have an issue of not being able to get to your data...
...wherever you happen to be from.
OK, Mike. Thank you very much! So, that's one data center.
Part of this huge battle developing in the clouds between the likes of Microsoft, Google, and Amazon...
...to take us into the future of cloud computing.